Oh, hello. I'm Jimmy Carr and I'm answering the internet.
I mean, good luck everyone. I've also got special ed. That's why I'm doing this.
It's not even a proper office. It's like a fraternity. Anyway. Um,
who was the one celebrity, uh, you would want at your funeral? Uh,
I, I, I mean, it's a funeral, isn't it? It's,
he's the purpose celebrity.
I think the, I think the.
Pope will give you a good send wouldn't he? Um, I would say, uh,
maybe I'm going to go with the obvious, I would say.
Oh, O J.
Yeah. Cause I think funerals are so dull. Right? So funeral, like I die,
my friends and family are like, Oh no, that's awful.
But I know they all watched the eight hour OJ documentary and they have
questions. And if he was there,
I guess over the finger sandwiches in the reception,
you would have to answer the questions.
And that would maybe take the edge off the day. Go.
What was it like the day you buried Jimmy? Aw.
We met OJ weird.
Okay. Would you rather be bald by the age of 20 or five foot?
Three with a full head of hair, so short or bald? I would go.
And this is just from talking to two ladies who are cruel. Um,
I think, I think height is more important than hair for that,
for the finest sex. And I think if you were going,
presumably that is an aesthetics thing to attract a mate and breed.
I think I'm going to have to go bald age 20.
And hopefully I had a good shape head because you can get a wig,
but I don't think you can get a foot's worth of platform heel.
Would you rather give up sex or porn for one year?
When you say give up sex,
do you mean like five minutes in this isn't going anywhere love.
Should we just pop Netflix on? I hear Jimmy. Car's got a new special.
Do you mean give up like that or do you mean give up no sex or pornography?
I actually gave up, uh, porn recently. Um, yeah, I don't watch porn. You know.
I finished up, I put my initials in at the end.
Uh, would you rather have a girl who talks too much during sex or is completely
silent? It makes no different in my basement.
They're never leaving. Um.
Would you rather know when you're going to die or how you're going to die?
I would re I would rather know the, when the one would be great. The how, yeah,
but the wind would be great. You could really plan.
I had a friend that died two years ago. Genuinely lived very wealthy, man.
We all thought he was a billionaire he's lost check, bounced, killing.
It.
Would you rather have a dog's personality and a cat's body? I mean that's,
I mean, yes. I don't have to read any further.
What a dog personally, in a cat's body, if we can manufacture these,
let's stop doing this podcast nonsense. Let's do that.
Let's put all our money into that. I can't personally in a dog's body.
It's just, would you rather a dog that was a Dick?
Would you rather a dog that didn't really like you or the most amazing cat has
ever been a toughie?
Would you rather go to jail for one year or go to jail with a Rubik's
cube and you can leave when it's done?
Yeah. Think about it. How long would it take to do a Rubik's cube? Ah,
about 10 minutes here. I mean, have you ever done
yes. Special needs presenters?
Would you rather be blind or dickless?
Can I be both? Um,
Dick like fully like Ken smooth? Yep. Have I always been Ken smooth? Nope.
You had it removed. Had it removed.
You also had site and got written. Then you went blind.
I would go, uh, I think, Hm.
I think what am I 46. I'll go. Dickless I've had, I mean,
the wear and tear on that thing.
Probably the upkeep I get so much done.
You know, when you go on the, the pornography, so you call it the internet.
I called it the pornography.
But when you finished with the pornography and book, train tickets and stuff,
be great. Which fictional character would you love to beat the out of?
I guess.
Which fictional character would you love to beat the out of? I'm going to go,
Jesus, I'm going to go Jesus.
And it's going to be one he's on the cross. It's worse than you thought it was.
It's me just piling on.
Is that bad? That's it right there.